would you say you're confident Kyrie
will be back or is that too strong
oh
if I was a betting man I would
I guess I would say he would be back why
would I say he wouldn't
um so confident is that that's too
strong
I think we hope I think Cuban made that
clear he's the number one priority
to have him come back so I would I would
second that
you think he's a max player
oh I'm not into paying the bills around
here
I'll leave that to uh to Mark to decide
on and Nico to decide on what
um
what his value is
it's kind of hard to eliminate losses
from the equation but do you think that
all things considered you guys created
uh that he that he liked the atmosphere
of the being part of the Mavericks and
that that will help draw him back yeah I
think he's enjoyed his time here um I
think he's at peace I think he has
enjoyed
being a Maverick and I think
um hopefully I'm not talking out of turn
that he he wants to be here
um and so hopefully that's the case when
you talk about the talent and the the
match of him and Luca
um you know is pretty Dynamic so
um but he has the the option
um very few are free agents
so he has he has that opportunity to uh
to explore so but hopefully we've done
everything to position him to to want to
stay but it's up to Cuban and Nico to
figure that out